The purpose of this video is to walk
through a simple demonstration of
programming a two-dimensional part with
some very simple geometry. Very common
but simple geometry. We're going to do
some milling, some pocketing, some
drilling, and so forth.
Along with this video, there should have
been a link for you to download a print
of the part that I'm going to walk
through.
And when we're done, I'm hoping that you
will have a good understanding of what
it takes to program a Herko, how simple
it is, and have a good understanding of
what kind of features are available.
Because doing this, I'm going to go
through um most of the areas of the
control such as part setup, tool setup,
actual part programming, graphics, file
manipulation, and so forth. So, it
should give you a really good overview
of what's available on the Hero Control.
The first thing I want to do is I need
to go and create a new program. Going to
do that by going to my program manager
screen.
The program manager screen is where I'm
going to create new, open existing, save
files.
If I go here to the disk operations
menu, you can see that it is just a
Windows Explorer file tree. Here I can
create new directories. cut, copy,
paste, um basically do any kind of file
manipulation that I can do on my uh
computer, I can do under disk
operations.
This program manager screen, however, is
just a uh an area where we have open
programs that are currently active,
whether they're the program we're
actually running or one that we are just
um getting ready to use for another job
or something like that.
So the first thing I want to do is I
want to create a new
conversational program.
It's going to name it no name whatever
the next available number is. In this
case there was already a no-name one. So
it created a no-name two.
And at this point I can go do a save as
or I can simply write the program and
run it without ever having saved it. If
I if this is for a fixture or something
like that, I don't actually have to save
the program if I don't choose to.
If I wanted to though, I could go to
save as.
I could go find uh the folder. I'm just
going to save this on my desktop. And
I'm going to put this as
um
video demonstration.
Click the save button. And now you can
see that it has a name. It also has a
path. It has been saved
to uh my desktop just as I as I uh told
it to. So next thing I want to do is I
want to go through and make sure the
tools that I want to use for this job
are set up.
Here we have a library of all the tools
that have ever been set up on this
particular machine.
Now, the part the tools that I want to
use may or may not have been set up. If
they haven't, I can simply go to the
tool setup screen,
highlight and type in a number for the
tool that I'm getting ready to describe,
and then walk through the information
that we have here on the screen. The
three tools that I need or the four
tools that I need, I'm going to use a
1/2 in endmill, a 3/8 inch endmill, 3/8
drill, and a 1/2 in 45° chamfer tool.
Those have already been set up. As you
can see here on the first screen, tool
one will be my/2in endmill.
I have things like the tool type. I want
to go through and select the type of
tool that this particular tool is. It's
an endmill in this case.
put in the diameter.
The tool length will be established at
the time of setup. Not necessary for
programming and using the graphics, but
it would be obviously if I'm going to
run the machine. And the second thing I
want to do after I've made sure that the
tool is
uh created and described correctly is go
through and associate some speeds and
feeds. The reason I do that is as I pull
this tool into a program, if the speeds
and feeds have been created already, it
will pop populate the speeds and feeds
fields in my program. Here I've
programmed it with surface footage of
800.
And based on the diameter, you can tell
that it calculated what the RPM will be.
I've given it a chip load
of 5000 per flute. and told it that
there were two flutes. Therefore, it was
able to calculate the inches per minute
feed rate. If I wanted, I could have put
a direct RPM
and a direct feed rate in. It would have
then calculated my surface footage and
my chip load.
So, I can program either way that I'm
used to programming. If I like to
program with surface footage and chip
load, the manuals that I have, the
experience that I have tells me to do
that, that's what I do. If I know a
direct RPM and a feed rate is inches per
minute that I like to use, I can put
those in either way. The control is very
flexible that way.
So, here we have tool one.
Tool two will be my 38 endmill and so
forth. Tool three is my drill. And we
continue to do this for all the tools in
our program.
Now, because we can accurately describe
the solid model that we're going to be
cutting, and we'll talk about that in a
minute, we need to be able to accurately
describe the tools that we're using.
Now, on a drill,
there's a drill point. You can see that
if I go to the advanced tool settings
screen and I highlight an individual
field here, I've done the diameter. You
can see that it shows on the graphic
what that field is asking for. And as I
cursor down through these, it shows you
exactly what that particular field is
asking for. And one of the things that
is not necessary, but very helpful to
put in
would be
the included angle on the tip of the
drill. That way when I'm looking at my
solid model, if I have drilled a hole
that needs to break through somewhere
and if I'm accurate with this
information, then um my graphic should
show exactly what my part's going to
look like.
Here we can tell it how many flutes
cutting direction, but most importantly,
it's going to sequentially add a color,
a different color on my graphics to
every tool that I use in the program.
However, if I choose to force a specific
tool to have a specific color, which I
do often when I'm engraving, I will
maybe put my face mill at a darker color
and my chamfer tool or my engraving tool
at a much lighter color just for
contrast. I can force that if I need to.
In this case, I don't care. I'm going to
let it sequentially pick all my tools.
So, now I've gone through and I've
created my program. I've set up my
tools. The next thing I want to do is
under part setup,
more stock geometry. I want to go in and
set up a piece of solid model. A solid
model for this piece of stock. Now, I
don't have to do this. As I hit draw,
the control will automatically create a
piece of stock a little bit larger than
whatever it is that I'm trying to cut.
However, if I want to be accurate, I can
go to the manual sizing. Do I want yes
or no? Do I want to create manually
create a piece of stock? Yes, I do. And
when I do that, you can see that it
gives me some information
um and some choices. One of which is
whether it's a box or a cylinder for the
type of
um material that I'm using. This case,
it's going to be a box.
You'll notice from your print, it's 6 in
x 6 in by 1 in thick.
And it's going to assume the front left
corner of this part is zero. That's I'm
going to leave that there. But if I were
going to program from the center, the
back left corner or somewhere else on
this part, I would then use these
reference positions here to then move
the stock into the the correct position
based on where it is that I want to
program from. But again, I'm going to
program from the front left corner of
this part just to keep it simple. So
I'll leave those at zero.
Now I've gone through done my part
setup,
my tool setup,
and now I am ready to do my part
programming.
So here are the menus that I have to
choose from. Any position blocks that I
may want to use. Probably going to use
that most often at the end of a program
to bring the part out to the operator to
be able to change parts, flip the part
over or what, what have you. I have
holes menu. Anything holes related,
boring, drilling, wrap, uh boring,
drilling, reaming or tapping will be
done under there. Any milling
operations, lines and arcs or simple
geometry will be done under the milling
tab. Anything that I program I can then
pattern. And we have some miscellaneous
features such as change part setups,
adding an M code for uh whatever reason,
whether it be for fixturing, pallet
change, what have you. And then we have
an NC program call where we can merge a
conversational program and an NC program
together.
First thing I'm going to start with, if
you look at the print, is I'm going to
machine that frame,
the quarterinch wide frame all the way
around the part. And that's a milling
feature. So I'm going to select milling.
It's a simple uh piece of geometry. So,
I'm going to select frame. If it was
something other than a circle, frame or
an ellipse, I could then select lines
and arcs. It created an arbitrary shape.
But in this case, I'm going to select
frame.
One of the things with the with the
conversational control, if you notice as
I highlight a field in the bottom left
corner of the screen, it's telling me
what it's asking for. Sometimes it's
more desript descriptive than others. It
depends on what it is that it's what
it's trying to create.
But in this case, it wants to know the X
and Y location of one of the corners of
the frame. Now frame has four corners
and I can describe that this location as
the corner of either one of any of the
corners on this particular frame. I'm
going to pick the bottom left corner and
that's going to be 0.25.25.
Now it's asking for the length in X and
the length in Y of the frame from that
corner. Well, we're going to travel 5
1/2 in
in the positive direction along X.
And we're going to do the same thing,
5.5 in the positive direction in the Y.
My Z start, that's the position I'm
going to wrap it to above the part
before I begin to do any feeding. And my
Z bottom will be the final depth of this
frame, which is 0.25 25
corner radius.
If
each one of those corners wanted had a
print dimension of 38 of an inch or
whatever, I could put that in here. I'm
going to put 01 10,000 radius. Just
enough to break those corners as it goes
around the frame.
The next is a start side. That means
where am I going to blend on? Circles
will generally blend at the 3:00
position. Frames will always blend at
the 6:00 position. But based on the
geometry that I am cutting or other
features on the part, that may not be
possible. So I'm able to then pick which
side I want to begin. I want the tool to
blend in from the bottom, the right, the
top, or the left side. So I have some
freedom on how that
how that tool enters into this cut.
Next, I have the corners tab.
In this case, I put a 10,000
arc on all four corners. But if I wanted
to control those corners independently,
you can see by the image here that each
corner has a number associated with it.
And I can control those with either a
radius
or a line length and angle for a chamfer
depending on my needs. Again, I'm just
going to leave these all at 10,000 just
to break that corner.
Next,
I come to the type of tool or the tool
that I'm going to use. I can either type
that tool number in if I wish, select it
from the list. In this case,
I can hit the tool
field here at the top, organize
everything by tool. It alphabetizes them
and organizes by tool. I can then go
down and find the endmill that I want,
which is a/2 inch endmill.
Or
I can sort them by number,
knowing I want tool one. Select the tool
here. So I have a couple different ways
to do that. I highlight the tool that I
want. I hit select tool. It then inserts
the tool into the program. You can see
that it puts the feed rate,
the RPM,
pec depth in this case, plunge feed,
anything that I have set up in the tool
can be populated here automatically.
Now I have to pick a strategy. What kind
of frame is this? If I leave it at on,
that'll be the center of the tool
traveling around the frame. There'll be
no cutter comp whatsoever. I can do an
inside or an outside frame. That means
the tool is going to blend on by a
parameter value, usually 3 millimeters.
You'll start off with a part by 3
millimeters, blend onto the cut, create
the frame, blend off that same amount,
inside and outside tangent.
Act exactly the same way. However, they
do not blend. Or I can make this a
pocket or a pocket island. In this case,
I'm going to cut an outside pocket or
excuse me, an outside frame.
If I choose, I can select the finishing
tab,
put in another tool here or the same
tool.
The roughing tool would then leave a
predetermined amount of material for
finishing
for the finish tool. If I do not use a
finishing tool, which I'm going to be
the case here, not going to use one,
then the roughing tool will take the
feature to final depth.
We go ahead and draw this.
Now we see that we do have the frame
that we created.
Graphics. I can roll this around, view
it from different angles.
I can look at it in any one of these
four views, top, front, right side, or
isometric.
I can look at it as a solid
just a wireframe
or a show all which is a combination of
the two.
And you notice that everything here tool
paths, rapids, plunges, so forth, they
all have a color associated with them.
And I can turn those on and off.
If I go back here now, you see that the
rapids have been turned on. they weren't
there previously. Um that you can see
that the center line of the tool running
around the part, stock geometry would be
in green, plunges would be in purple, so
forth.
I typically like to look at things in
the solid model view.
It can be transparent
or opaque.
Here we see it. Here we see it in
transparent. I can actually see through
the part a little bit. So if I had parts
or things that were coming in from other
other sides on a multiaxis part, for
example, I'd be able to see those very
well.
Okay. So now that we've created the
frame, let's go in and do that large
circle pocket. So I go to my program,
hit the next block, also going to be a
milling block. It's going to be a
circle. And I just begin to fill out the
information. And the center of the
circle is 3 in and 3 in in X and Y. The
radius for that, it's a 4 in diameter.
So 2 in radius.
Start at 0.05 above. I'll go down half
an inch.
My final dimension
of depth. My start angle. Again, it's
going to begin at the 3:00 position to
blend in and off of this particular
circle. But I can pick anywhere between
0 and 360°.
Zero is fine. In this case, I'm going to
leave it alone. Again, I'm going to use
tool one. I know that. I'm just going to
type in the tool number. In this case,
it's going to be a pocket boundary.
Spiraling outward from the center. I can
also go from the in outside towards the
center. And I can use some um what we
call adaptive path or high-speed
pocketing routines as well, whether it
be zigzag or a oneway.
This case is just going to be simple
pocketing outward speeds and feeds.
The tool stepover percentage, our pec
depth, plunge feed, all that have set
for us. I hit the draw button and now I
have a circle in the middle of my part.
Continuing to build here.
Got my next block. Also going to be a
milling circle.
Same center,
different radius.
This case I'm going to wrap it to
minus.4 in my Z because I already have a
pocket that's a/ inch deep.
My final depth is going to be 750.
Again, this time I'm going to use tool
two.
still going to be a pocket.
The rest of the information that came in
is fine.
And now I have a separate pocket. And
you can see that the tool number
changed. So the color changed.
Last feature that we have on the print
is that bold circle pattern.
You notice that I keep going back to
what is called the review screen. The
review screen is a table of contents, if
you will, of the blocks in your program.
Some of these blocks will just be one
page as they are in the simple geometry
we've programmed so far. Sometimes they
will have subblocks that will show up in
that right corner such as lines and arcs
that may be used to uh create a
particular feature or a holes block
which we're going to see next.
Go to the
next block.
This time it's going to be holes.
I'm only going to drill in this case.
I'm not going to worry about a center
drill. But if I wanted to, I'd go under
my drill, select center drill, spot
drill, or whatever. Here, I'm just going
to go right to my drill for simplicity.
Rapid to point 4.
I'm going to drill all the way through
the part using tool three.
Now, RPM,
feed rate. Here's a pec depth that I'd
already put in for this particular tool.
I can change it if I want. If I zero it
out, the tool will go to depth without
any pecs.
If I put pec depth values in there,
it'll stop at that particular depth and
do one of two things. It will either
stop for a standard pec where it rapids
all the way out of the hole each time or
it'll stop just as a chip breaker and
pause at that particular depth until the
chips are cleared for a couple
revolutions. this case I'm going to
leave it at standard.
Now from here from I would continue to
build my processes. I would go to next
hole operation. Maybe it's a tap,
maybe it's another drill, a center
drill, then a drill, whatever it would
be. I would continue to build the the
processes or the what that I'm going to
do. Then I'm going to tell it where
either XY locations or a bolt circle. In
this case, we're going to use bolt
circle.
Simply asks how many holes are in the
bolt circle. 1 2 3 4 5 6. There's only
seven holes,
but that is a equally spaced eight hole
bolt circle that's being showed. So, I'm
going to say eight. That will give me
the equal spacing that I need for the
seven holes. And we're going to end up
skipping one of those holes. So, I need
number of holes is eight.
The center is 3 and three. The radius in
this case it says it is a 3.5 diameter
bolt circle. So 3.5 diameter divided by
two.
And the start angle. Start angle is very
important. Start angle tells me where
hole number one goes. In this particular
case I can put one either at 0° which is
3:00 or 90°
which is 12:00.
I could also put one at the 6:00 or 9:00
position. I'm going to put one at the
12:00 position for hole one. So, I'm
going to say 90°.
Now, the reason that's important is
because that's hole number one. If I
then count the holes going in the
counterclockwise direction, we see a one
at the top. 2 3 4 5 at the 6:00
position. 6 7 Whole number eight is
missing. So that's the number that I put
in my skip list. I skip hole number
eight.
Now when I go to draw this,
you see that I have a bolt circle
with the skipped hole. Now something is
wrong. Doesn't look like my print
here. I can use my graphics to go to the
exact block that has a problem. When we
build a program, we have
only a limited number of things we can
call it. It's mill circle. It's a mill
frame. It's a holes block. It's a mill
contour. Well, what particular feature
was cut by which particular block? Well,
in this case, I can go to data block
search.
I can highlight
the feature that I want. In this case,
it's going to be this the the hole. Jump
to the block and it takes me to that
particular block and that particular
feature. I'm going to go back one
operation
to my hole and I see that I have a 3/8
diameter hole that I'm using the wrong
tool for. The other thing about
conversational programming is I can
change things on the fly. I don't have
to go back to a post-processor. Or I can
just simply go to my select tool from
list. I can organize by type. I can go
to my drills,
find the 375
hole,
tool 15 in this case,
select it. All my feed rates and
everything still came in.
Go back and draw it. And it is now
repaired.
Very easy to recover from something as
you go. And one of the other beautiful
things I like about conversational is
let's say that I want to put a chamfer
on the inside of this circle and the
outside of this frame. Now I can
reprogram that very easily. But I can
also go to my my tool review screen or
program review screen and pick these
first two blocks. The mill frame outside
that I want to chamfer and the pocket
circle, the largest one that I want to
in the center that I want to chamfer.
I can copy those,
paste them, and then simply change the
depth.
I'm going to go
30,000 deep
on that frame.
I'm going to go 30,000 deep
on the mill circle. It's going to be an
inside this time instead of a pocket.
But I'd also need to change the tool. In
this case, I'm going to use tool 13,
which is a half inch chamfer mill. And I
forgot to change that on the one
previously. So, I'm going to do that
now.
Now when I hit draw,
you can see
that we do have a chamfer now on the
inside of that
circle and on the edge of that frame. I
didn't have to reprogram anything.
Again, this was simple geometry, a frame
and a circle. Not that hard to recreate.
However, a lines and arcs uh contour
with with uh
lots of subblocks, if you will, um would
be much more difficult to recreate. So,
I can simply copy and paste that. Now,
here we see the
program review screen. Again, this is a
table of contents of the program itself.
If I highlight the holes block, now you
can see an example of what the subblocks
look like. One thing we haven't done yet
and that is
if I ran this job today and I have to
run it again six months from now, I may
not remember what I called it, but I
know what it looks like. From the
graphic screen, you see we have this
little snapshot button. If I hit
snapshot, it'll tell me that an image
was stored in the program. I now go back
to my program manager. You can see in
the bottom left corner an image that
resembles what we just programmed.
And I can also under program properties
I can put some information here that
will appear in the in this uh text
window in the center of the screen. So
based on what I've named the program,
where I have saved it, what the cutter
path is, or excuse me, the uh file path,
what the part looked like in this
description, I can put here in this text
box. I should be able to accurately
describe whatever part is that I want to
program, be able to easily find that
later on. One last thing that I would
like to talk about. If I go here into
any one of these blocks,
we can easily change
from metric to inch. The bottom of the
screen, you can't see it here. I'm going
to pull this up so you'll be able to see
it.
the bottom of your screen on the machine
itself or on your desktop software,
which is what I'm using here. We can
simply touch the word inch in this case,
and it's going to pop up a menu that
says, "Do you want to switch to the
metric units?" Yes, I do. If I select
yes, you'll notice that all of my
coordinates in the program,
my tooling information
for this tool number one was a/ inch
inmill. is now a 12.7 mm. All of my
parameters, my digital readout,
everything literally switched to
millimeters. So, I could program off a
metric print without having to convert
anything. And when I'm done, I simply go
back to inch or imperial units.
Everything's switched back and I'm able
to then program back an inch again. Very
good way to program off a metric print
if you're not used to it. and it
switched to inch uh numbers, which is
something that in my case means
something more to me. And it's better
for me to run an inch than in metric.